so so I I wanted to bring this up with
you and it's this happened this happened
in between from when we set up the
interview until now but I figured this
is the perfect you'd be one of the
perfect people to ask so liver King
yeah I'm sure I know I know but we have
it's all Maddie I'm standing by him
I think those are doctors those [ __ ]
emails okay so liver King he pushes this
ancestral lifestyle which is basically
eat like steroids
traditional steroids the ones like they
used in the 80s like Ultimate Warrior
did okay well what I mean was
he pushes and says he [ __ ] very funny
he pushes ancestral living which is like
you know he eat eat cow balls and eat
raw liver and eat all that so before we
get into the steroid stuff what did you
think about that uh that angle of of his
well now I in my opinion his grift
yeah we're on the same page here but um
the the sad thing about the liver King
story is that actually a lot of what
he's suggesting is good I mean he he
places emphasis for instance on
going out in the sun getting sunlight on
your body which is which is essential
for vitamin D formation which is which
is a precursor for hormones and and it
affects your mood Etc your libido I mean
it's a big thing lots of people are
vitamin D deficient and most people
would benefit from getting more sun he
places a lot of emphasis on getting
proper sleep and again sleep is sleep is
an incredibly important part of of being
a healthy person I mean there are
studies that show for instance that if
you sort out your sleep if you go from
sleeping five hours a night to sleeping
seven or eight you can double your
testosterone levels so actual studies
that have that have Quantified that I
mean it's it's it has that big of an
effect it's that important so a lot of
the stuff that he's saying is is good
eating organ meat yes is good I mean you
don't need to eat like he says he does
two pounds of liver a day I mean that
seems like a lot yeah you you you're
cruising you're cruising for a bruising
when you do that because there's a lot
of copper in liver and what you don't
want is copper toxicity there's a lot of
vitamin A and liver too right I mean I
think I think that generally that the
recommended daily intakes of vitamins
are probably uh vitamins and minerals
are probably much too low than they
should be but even so two two pounds of
liver is excessive
um I mean I don't I don't know exactly
what benefits consuming
uh testicles would have I mean I suppose
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to consume you're trying to
consume the steroid hormones that are
produced in the in the testicles so it
might have some kind of effect I'm sure
but um so yeah so so that kind of stuff
the stuff bar the steroids I think
is a lot of it would actually benefit
um you know men who aren't aren't in the
best shape men who want to to improve
their their lives
um uh and also would some of it will
probably be quite good fun too I think
but yes it's the steroid thing that is
uh that is the elephant in the room
um it always was it's just it's
unfortunate that you can't like to me
I've always lived my life as kind of an
open book
and to me it's like the when you when
you don't hide these major things I
think people are more more or less
willing to let it go like Royce made the
point of like if you're just from day
one been like hey do all these things
are great for you but also between you
and me I'm also like [ __ ] right you
know what I mean I think people would
have been more prone to go because I
think like even if you're anti-steroid
or if you're Pro steroids whatever I'm
willing to take advice from a guy who
also happens to take steroids because
he's probably doing a countless other
things just you know you don't just do
steroids and look magically good yeah
this guy obviously has a [ __ ] really
good input he probably has really good
advice aside from the steroids so if
he'd just been uh up front and been like
yeah look I take HGH and steroids too
but this is my like I still eat like how
many guys you see that uh online there
are influencers that'll admit that and
then also go you know like more plates
more dates a good example of a guy
that's like look I'll tell you all my
[ __ ] experiences doing different [ __ ]
but some you know you don't have to
steroid but you can also take the advice
like I do some of the more plates like
his hair loss advice like I'm taking the
same [ __ ] he does now you know there's
some good advice out there to be had by
something didn't work for me well you
waited too long yeah I know
um but so going back here to liver King
I do believe that it's it's more of uh I
think if you're up front people do that
I I my biggest issue and Roy I wonder
what you think about this is
you're selling false hope to people
because you know of course most I think
most adults would would have been I I
mean I wasn't shocked he was on steroids
I think most people with the eyeball
test be like yeah that guy's on steroids
he's like 45 that's you know it's really
hard to keep that low body fat and that
much muscle at that age it's not that
you can't be in great shape you can but
it's just you could I'm like okay that's
clearly steroids but I think the issue
is is when when you're pushing
supplements when you're pushing stuff
and going you could be just like me then
the issue is and you have 18 19 year old
kids that give up you know
yeah well the thing well actually you
know um I wrote a piece about liver King
at the beginning of the year that I
didn't run because uh I thought or I was
I was told that he might be appearing in
the end of men with me so
right I thought where it would probably
be probably you know be a bad idea for
me to [ __ ] where I eat so I didn't I
didn't um I didn't run the piece but the
piece was actually about
well the piece was about the fact that
um you know liver King talks about
honoring his ancestors and you can talk
about the ancestral
the nine ancestral tenets and it's all
it is about honoring your ancestors and
the way that they lived and then but
then your life is a lie I mean I mean
there's there's probably nothing that
annoys tradition people in traditional
societies more than telling lies yeah
you know like you're not you're not a
trusted member of the tribe if you go
around telling lies
um so so that's that's kind of what I
was what I was talking about in that
piece in particular but um yeah I mean
he is selling people full tape he has
been saying to people if you do the nine
ancestral tenant if you follow the nine
ancestral tenants you can look like me I
mean the man is the man's what 45 45
yeah 45. uh I mean
you know I mean that's a hell that's a
hell of a claim and yet people and yet
people people will believe it because
first of all because people don't
people don't know enough about steroids
and about performance enhancing drugs
because so many people are on them and
so many people lie and second of all I
just think that yeah I mean a teenager
looking at him will will think man I I
yeah I really want to be like that yeah
I I but I believe him you know look and
look at his uh crazy lifestyle this is
so cool you know I can just look like
him if I do all this stuff and then yes
you end up
you end up um actually doing more harm
than good because really what you want
to tell an 18 year old is um
you know you're in the prime of your
life uh no you won't look like me
because I take steroids but you can
actually you know have a great physique
and feel great about yourself but you
won't look like me because you're not
taking you're not spending eleven
thousand dollars a month on growth
hormone that was that was the other
thing first off you're overpaying but
secondly he it's that is a that was like
a even if it's eight thousand eight
thousand dollars a month right let's say
on human growth hormone and then it was
was it was testosterone it was it was a
couple other things and it was it it it
it's it's this it's okay for me again
I'm a bit here's the other one the rock
is another one right like the rock is
another one that bothers me for the same
reason which is look
is Rock on steroids absolutely if I'm
lying sue me okay rock go prove that
you're not but the rocks on steroids
obviously I was I was told on Instagram
it was because he grinds hard oh you're
right he rises and grow I forgot about
the grinding but and by the way the rock
is a genetic freak even when he was
playing football it was genetic freak
but what bothers me is that then then
he's pushing oh look is this is my this
is my energy drink and you could look
like me and all you have to do is is
make sweaty videos in the gym and with
chains on your and it's like okay
people look at that and and then see my
my problem with that stuff was also is
then it that I think I agree with you
right it has the inverse effect because
a lot of people like I'm not progressing
fast enough then an 89 year old [ __ ] up
their entire underground system by
taking steroids at 19 and that's another
problem that actually wouldn't mind
talking about the influencers and and
how many 18 19 year old 20 year olds are
hopping on steroids like and ruining
their lives in my opinion uh because
it's it's the fitness industry because
of because of Jim shark because of
people like this because of the people
like the rock that pushed this false you
know sense of hope and then then these
same influencers that take steroids and
be like hey guys don't forget to get
vaccinated and boosted it's like go [ __ ]
off all right man I have to correct you
on one thing though the rock is not a
genetic freak he's half black half
Samoan he's a genetic exactly what he
was supposed to okay that's fair enough
it's not exactly a freak of nature his
dad was Rocky Johnson yeah he's Samoan
that's related like a Wild Samoan that's
a really good point but um I I think
that's just what what I guess in a
broader term I've have you noticed an
uptick on these influencers that are
clearly using Pharmaceuticals and
pushing I don't know man all these
pre-workouts and all these chemicals and
all that stuff
well that was a there was a more place
more dates video about
uh teens on Tick Tock who were obviously
well I say who obviously who were saying
that they were doing Psalms so Psalms
are Psalms are a newer class of of
um performance enhancing drugs that are
like steroids they were developed
originally as anti-cancer drugs
um or anti-muscle wastage drugs rather
for cancer patients and it was
discovered that they actually you know
they have animal really serious anabolic
effects and they're legal for the most
part I think one of the places that
they're not legal is Australia but
otherwise they're legal in the US
because they can be sold as research
chemicals so it's easy for people to get
it's easy for teenagers to get them it's
easy for anybody to get them so yeah a
lot of teenagers are hopping onto Psalms
and other stuff and
um
and it and it's a shame because what
they're doing is they're sacrificing
their their newbie gains you know
they're just they're getting their
newbie gains in record time
rather than in two years you know they
get them in six months or whatever and
um and then yes they're ruining their
endocrine systems but it's uh yeah it's
it's a it's a sad thing to see
influencers who are so obviously on
performance enhancing drugs chilling
some kind of um pre-workout as the key
to getting a shredded physique and you
know looking like uh
looking like an Instagram model or a an
action film star or something like that
um when in fact actually the real secret
is that they're on they're on whatever
they're on they're either on um steroids
or tests or or Psalms or a combination
of things it's just it's just so it's so
um well I mean it's it they're just
lying you know I mean it's all built on
Deception so you mean if I take BCAAs in
my pre-workout I'm not gonna look like
deliver King oh God is that why I don't
look like him that's why you know you
know what it is I don't take an offbeat
you don't take enough piece that's what
the problem you know what they say they
say more is always better yeah also you
know another good channel that covers
this and I don't know if you've seen a
shredded science
I've seen some videos yeah he's pretty
good about about calling about calling
all that stuff out but I I do think that
it's this it's the Pfizer rates like we
said at the very beginning where it's
everything is just take the chemical
layout there's a chemical layout there's
a drug there's a chemical there's a drug
and and instead of doing the thing at
least you know look I'm not going to
pretend that even if you live everything
perfectly and you'll be perfectly and
get all the sleep that you're gonna look
like someone that's Genetically Enhanced
but it's it kind of it kind of feels
like it's just the easy way out it's a
cheat code it's it's I think in general
a loss of patience in society too right
like would you rather bust your ass for
like 10 years to get in Peak condition
or do a 12-week psycho with Ryan
Reynolds trainer and so you look like
Deadpool you know yeah yeah exactly yeah
no it's no it's true and and also
and also again it's it's it's another
instance of people being sold
being sold
um
treatments remedies whatever you want to
call them without actually having a full
appreciation of the side effect profile
um I mean you know if you could if you
could show an eight an 18 year old what
his life would be like with the totally
ruined endocrine system then uh he
probably he might he might still take it
he might not but I mean Ronnie Ronnie
Coleman obviously is a is a salutatory
story what's happened to him I mean it's
so sad
watching him with the with with the one
of the talk about somebody else who was
even out forgets there before we even
before the stairs was a genetic freak
um to see him having to be on Walkers
now like using hand Walkers is so sad
because he is you know that and I also
from every story here one of the nicest
guys to really nice guy and he and he
just he fought he [ __ ] him she [ __ ]
himself up and and that's I think that's
what happens that's what happens with
with a lot of people but I mean it's
it's that you know bigger stronger
faster but in in in reality it's like
you said that's a really good point if
you had a time machine if you could do
like a Christmas story and be like look
look yeah look you're gonna you're gonna
have great abs at 19. and also it's a
waste because you have Peak testosterone
when you're 18 19 20 years old so you're
you're right you're you're wasting what
God already gave you you know
um so now I'm about to hit 40. I think
I'm gonna start on a baseball player
amount of steroids okay that's The Sweet
Spot a baseball player amount of stuff I
want to do NFL amounts you don't want to
do like you know what I mean Pro fighter
amount just a baseball amount I'm what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna I'm Cuban so
I'm gonna do the Sammy says this thing
where he turned himself white I think I
think that whatever that was I'm gonna
do whites yeah that looks great yeah he
looked natural he looked he looked he
looked fantastic he looked as natural as
this guy